decent person is horrified by what
happened yesterday in parkland every
thoughtful person knows something
horrible is going on in American society
tragedies like this happen for a reason
and it probably doesn't have a lot to do
with guns the percentage of American
households with firearms has dropped
dramatically over the past 35 years
meanwhile the number of mass shootings
has risen if you're over 40 you did not
grow up in a country like this so the
question is what happened it could be a
lot of things far more Americans than
ever before takes psychiatric
medications or outbursts of violence a
potential side effect we don't know but
it's possible does the social
atomization of modern society play a
role in all this well spending life
online does cause alienation we know
that last week we interviewed author
Johann Hari who has studied the dramatic
rise of depression in this country as he
pointed out the most common answer to
the question how many close friends do
you have is now zero the lack of
meaningful relationships does cause
despair perhaps in rare cases it drives
some to mass murder meanwhile the
nuclear family has collapsed nationwide
does a generation of boys growing up
without fathers pose a threat to this
country of course it does why wouldn't
it fatherlessness is one feature common
to many mass shooters nobody's surprised
by that
now what about men more broadly as a
group men are not thriving in this
country right now ignore the propaganda
and there's a lot of it and instead look
at the numbers men kill themselves more
graduate less and of course commit
pretty much a hundred percent of mass
shootings it's a disaster which for some
reason our elites persist in ignoring in
March this show will begin a month-long
series every Wednesday on what is
happening to men we hope it'll be
interesting but why haven't we been
talking about this for years we're not
saying any of these factors caused the
massacre we saw yesterday we don't know
that we are saying we ought to do our
honest best as a nation to figure out
what exactly is going on here but we're
not doing that that vital conversation
has been drown out and made impossible
by mindless screeching about gun control
led by blustery charlatans in the media
you know exactly who they are and also
in Congress whose only
religion is moral preening they aren't
trying to solve the problem their aims
are darker than that press a little bit
and you'll see it sensible guttin
reforms you hear that phrase a lot
you've heard it all day today on cable
news what does that does that mean
sensible gun reforms banning bump stocks
no a piece on voxcom today calls for a
landmark gun control bill like the one
Australia past 22 years ago in 1996
that's the law that liberals are always
telling you about but the Australian law
wasn't gun control and it wasn't a
voluntary buyback no matter what they
tell you it was gun confiscation a
wholesale mandatory disarmament of the
entire civilian population imagine what
would happen if you tried that here in
this country America is not Australia
for a bunch of reasons including our
history and our Bill of Rights
imagine federal officials marching from
house to house seizing hundreds of
millions of firearms from law-abiding
citizens and then finding and
imprisoning those who resist Voxx
approvingly calls this a leadership in
fact it's a recipe for bloodshed and
civil war it's nuts
yet it is a common fantasy on the left
Dan Pfeiffer was a senior advisor to
Barack Obama now he's a contributor at
CNN of course last fall Pfeiffer wrote
an article attacking his fellow
Democrats for what he bluntly called
fake moderation on guns his advice was
this stop pretending to respect the
Constitution and instead focusing on
appointing judges who will nullify it
the goal gun seizures ammunition
regulation the disarmament of the
American population a country where only
the people in charge have guns and
everybody else obeys in the wake of
yesterday's shooting Pfeiffer's pieces
going viral on the left what he wrote is
what they believe so let's stop lying
about this the calls you're hearing
today for gun control have nothing to do
with protecting Americans from violence
which are witnessing is a kind of class
war the left hates rural America red
America gun-toting America the America
that elected Donald Trump they hate them
progressives are still in charge of most
of the major institutions in this
country and they despise the autonomy of
an armed population they want collective
punishment for the sins of a few they
seek to obliterate a cork on
to snow right rather than trying to
mitigate its downsides they call it gun
control but it's not it's people control
for the left
voters who can't be controlled can't be
trusted